our next guest lets a nearby Emory
University where I can only assume he
borrowed ideas from fellow students he's
done for asking thought-provoking
questions that he supposedly heard at
his local deli on other TV show
one of the sharpest minds in the NFL me
if not the most original
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
co-host of the NFL Network's good
morning football not really a cause
because there's four people on there
sorry say four host some context here
then it's 7:00 a.m. Eastern wait for the
introduction Super Bowl Sunday 8 and a
half hour edition of NFL gameday morning
airs at 9:00 a.m. Eastern on the NFL
Network welcome Peter Schrager happy to
be here it's good I'm here for my
roasting let's go alrighty let me let me
let the audience you in case they're not
aware of what happened tragically and
we'll move on after this but you know we
came up with a poll question when they
started out with Julian Edelman is
greatness and then Pauli goes you know
hey what about you know if you did
Calvin Johnson or Julian Edelman whose
career would you would you want so we
put it up and we talked about it and we
you know decided who we wanted so then
all of a sudden Paulie goes uh a Peter
striker just put this up and he's taking
credit for this he said oh hey just
thinking out loud
no what about whose career would you
take Julian Edelman czar Calvin Johnson
so we started crushing him on the show
social media is usually nice so he nice
enough to come on and then he said that
he got it from his local deli guy in the
deli in New York yeah so these guys
exist they just want to talk sports all
day long and he said to me let me ask
you and so you didn't know but you you
took it and then kind of made it yours
here's I listen to the Dan Patrick show
daily so I am sort of guilty on this one
that you caught me in one episode or
apparently I wasn't listening I said on
Twitter guys who would you rather have
as a career Calvin Johnson or Julian
Edelman and the responses were their
responses on Twitter weren't like Julian
Calvin it was you stole
then the Dan Patrick Army came out in
force and I would call him a mob an
angry mob the fan base for this show is
legit I would just say that I had to
turn off Twitter and I eventually
deactivated
now did you pick between Julian Edelman
or Calvin Johnson yeah and my answer
apparently wasn't a popular one I said
I'll take Julian Edelman and the rings
and football people were not happy with
no I agreed with you Michael Irvin
agreed with you well agreed with us and
then agreed with you through great tweet
though guys yes but you know I said I
got Super Bowl rings I can't tell I can
tell the history of the NFL but I need
Julian Edelman to tell the history of
the NFL right yes Calvin Johnson the
only thing I will tell in the history of
the NFL that deals with him is
completing the process of it the same
that's it I mean I just put in a
wonderful career if money was equal and
it was just about the numbers you put up
or Talent I'd still go with Julian
Edelman he won Super Bowls had two of
the most iconic plays in the history of
the Super Bowl Julian Edelman is the
second leading receiver and career
receptions in the post season behind
Jerry Rice that kind of stat to me is
something that I will put up in high
regard now Calvin Johnson's got the
individual statistics we can debate
about all day long and football fans are
so angry about it but I cherish the
hardware and the Rings to me are what
matters Julian Edelman is on the cusp of
winning a third one this weekend
all right the Commissioner is gonna have
a State of the Union address what do you
expect to happen when it comes to the
topic of the New Orleans Saints and the
than the LA ring I think people are
outraged that you know he hasn't come
out and done a press conference
beforehand he's gonna come out today
he's gonna address it and here's what I
tell Saints fans the toothpaste is out
of the - there's no going back like
they're not gonna replay it so what do
you want from Goodell what do you want
to hear what I think he's gonna say is
that we're gonna look in the offseason
we're gonna try to address the replay
officials and the review and you had
Cameron Jordan here I feel for Saints
players
I feel for Sean pay and I feel for
Saints fans but this is part of the game
it's human error and I think Roger
Goodell is gonna go up there and say
we're gonna look at everything we can do
but I also wanted to kind of take a hard
line here and say it's not change
like this is what it is and if you're a
fan of the Rams you feel discredited
this week and last week because all
you're hearing about is the Saints and I
know those Rams players
I know those Rams coaches they've had up
just about enough talking about a missed
call when Drew Brees had the ball on
overtime that team was up 13 nothing at
home and they had four possessions in
the fourth quarter and in OT and scored
three points Rams people they've had
just enough about this missed call go
get the job done at home yeah I'm there
with you because I can look at that call
and yes it did prevent the Saints but
the Saints had these opportunities the
Saints didn't play a good game and I
give credit to the Rams for being
resilient you did what you're supposed
to do in overtime you stopped them and
got the ball Kansas City is not here
because they didn't stop Tom Brady if
you get to overtime it is that's why
they have a coin toss it it is a coin
toss if you're going to win or not I
don't want to change over time because
overtime worked in New Orleans we have a
problem in Kansas City because the
Patriots took advantage of it if Kansas
City wins the toss goes down and scores
a touchdown nobody sent well we got a
revamp oh right right if people wanted
to see my homes it was like sorry make a
stop third and ten third and ten thirty
nine stop them once you get them home
why don't you think the Commissioner
just came out and said what you said and
set it right away you don't have to
apologize you're the commissioner this
is your fan base you want them to know
you stand up and you're gonna be in
front front and center and just say hey
look I'll sit down on the mothership or
the NFL Network and I will address this
that's all it's a great question and I'm
not a PR executive I don't know how
these statements get released don't know
when they get released
I do think he'll address it head-on
today I think he'll have a prepared
statement and I'll be fine but I also
think when you start talking about this
stuff without a few hours to digest
without a few hours to cover people are
an angry mob now we're a week removed
you can address it you could say we're
gonna talk about it in the owners
meetings in March and we'll go from
there but in the hours after that play
and the days after that play it's all
anyone want to talk about and Goodell he
was smart on this one I think let's wait
to the Super Bowl cooler heads will
prevail and I'll address it there well I
got a heads up this is the day before
maybe two days before I said you know
what I
keep an eye on nikhyl Roby Coleman
getting fine for the helmet-to-helmet
and then I thought if that happens then
the topic continues he gets fine for the
helmet-to-helmet
and you know it you know i there the
outrage is died down a little bit but I
do think that the Saints deserve just at
least don't tell privately Sean Payton
hey we effed up like we wiped I was the
thing when he came out this first
comment was I spoke to vinovich already
is vinovich hasn't spoken you know we
had vinovich on our show on NFL now
we're not vinovich I'm sorry we spoke to
al River on who's the head of the
officials
he came on after the divisional round
because there's a lot of controversy in
some of the calls and the Chargers and
ravens and he's like I'll face the music
I'll come right on you can ask me any
play we did he didn't come on our show
after that game with the Saints in the
Rams and and it's not that I think he's
hiding but I think on such a stage in
such a love way he's probably told not
to come on I don't think it's at
anyone's best interest to address that
in a public setting without all the
messaging completely buttoned up and I
look at that play we're talking to Peter
Schrager the NFL Network good morning
football I look at the play and I wonder
if you just have it my suggestion was I
have another official who's in the
stadium and his job is just to keep the
officials on the field honest just to
help them and that is if you see
something that's egregious or if you
want to just do in the last two minutes
of a game or the last two minutes of of
each half whatever it is protect your
product protect those officials it's a
it's the hardest sport to efficient even
though that officials right there and
that play is right in front of you just
and don't have all-star groups don't
have an all-star who is working week
three in Cincinnati that's fine if they
know each other let's work with each
other because I wouldn't want an
all-star group of Danette you're right I
would yes but I'm comfortable with them
and if you were on my team you know
weekend and week out and you said to me
hey Bill come here you know they total
up here I trust you as my teammate well
as an official you're going to protect
me because we did games week one week
ten we go to dinner on Friday night we
know each other Saturday like there's a
camaraderie there but in the heat of the
moment if you don't know that guy here's
one thing I will say though there was a
report from Adam Schefter who I respect
to the utmost ability
and I think he's the greatest that that
does this with Glaser right and rapport
there's those guys who are the inside
his report or but you don't get the
other stuff I would never see a little
so that's called plagiarism the report
was that four of the officials or from
the state of California and people were
looking into it that's when I say okay
time out here these guys have been
working 25 years in the league do you
think they had a long play I'm gonna get
into officiating I'm gonna wait for the
Rams to move to st. Louis
then the st. Louis Rams are gonna move
back to LA and then I'm gonna call more
penalties against the Rams than the
Saints the entire game but but with a
minute left in the fourth quarter after
they ran the ball and then threw the
ball to Michael Thomas I am then going
to not throw a flag not even throw a
flag that was wrong not throw a flag
because then I'll get my sweet revenge
and the Rams will go to the Super Bowl
that's ridiculous well Ed Hochuli is
from Wisconsin sure like I never thought
man I don't know that call against the
Packers I yeah I I it's gotten to that
point it's too far everybody is from
somewhere yes the replacement refs and
they had photos look at the guy he's
like wearing the same Jersey call him
the same thing if the Rams win this
weekend yeah doc got done McVeigh's it's
McVeigh's world you know I did a
sit-down with him that's gonna air on
NFL Network on Sunday but I did it on
Friday and I got to spend a lot of time
with him and I know the guy pretty well
on a personal level and you'd think that
he lives his Hollywood lifestyle like
he's going out with Gigi Haddad and he's
hanging out at the clubs and he's that
hide he's the most boring dude you could
imagine he loves football I hung out
with him on the bye week it was after
that Chiefs Rams game and I'm thinking
okay I'm getting the Sean McVeigh expect
for gonna go to the Soho House and he's
like do you want to watch a Cardinals
Bears but I think this dude beats
Belichick at 33 years old and Belichick
66 years old if he beats him get ready
for an off season of McVeigh McVeigh
McVeigh and I'm curious to see what kind
of global superstar he will because in
our football world he's a hotshot
everyone loves him he's great but we're
talking Ellen show we're talking movie
cameos like la will explode if they've
got a 33 year old hotshot
and I'm curious to see what happens if
he wins the coverage if Brady loses
another Super Bowl or if rady wins
another I don't know if it matters if if
he wins and you know does it change
anything and you know the pantheon of
great athletes are oszi above Jordan but
if he loses another one now we're sort
of in the LeBron James area where we
start to look and go yeah but he lost
four Super Bowls here we have this
debate and art we do a three-hour
football show in March and April and
June the Brady Montana debates got some
some tread of the tire the Montana
apologists will say this for know 16
touchdowns in Super Bowls zero
interceptions never threw a pick in a
Super Bowl end was flawless four for
four if Brady goes five of nine the
appearances are what matters I think
nine times all that stuff but five of
nine versus four of four is a very
interesting debate where do you stand on
it I think in this day and age of parody
and and how many teams there are and
there's thirty two and there's free
agency I think what they have done and
to get to nine Super Bowls is the
hardest achievement I think what Brady
has done in this era where every year
it's a new NFC team and yet here we are
Patriots in the AFC I think that's the
highest accomplishment and I'm right
there with you because the same thing
with LeBron okay Mike was six and oh and
NBA Finals got it but you got to get
there and for LeBron to get there now
you know we look at LeBron sort of the
way with you know Brady you're in a bad
division or you know it's easy to get in
with the AFC East you know all of these
things that we looked art searching did
anybody look at what Michael Jordan was
going through when they go you know you
went through a lane but it feels like we
just put up these hurdles these
imaginary hurdles to say well you know
the AFC sucks okay that's not Brady's
fault he can't say you know what second
thought I got to go through a tougher
division like can you put me in the
whatever the North yeah you know and so
it feels like no matter what Brady does
we're gonna try to find something to
chip away at him because you had my
here and you have the old guard that
holds on to Montana and the old guard
holds on to Michael Jordan yep and I
think that's what happens I see
similarities with Brady and and LeBron
with how we view the number of times but
also the losses stand out more than the
victories do and that's not fair to them
last week's AFC Championship win was a
really important win for his legacy
because they have been favored in 67
straight games 67 straight games and
they played this underdog card that was
nausea and they're still trying to do
nausea and their favorite in the game
you know they're underdogs no one
believes in us everyone believes we're
still we're still here yeah I know and
can't avoid you and yet that game they
were underdogs they were on the road
they had to answer the call and my
Holmes was amazing my home scored 31
points
I'm 32 offensive plays in the second
half and it wasn't enough I thought that
was an awesome against Belichick who
makes the adjustments mahomes was
perfect in the second half and it wasn't
enough because Brady it was that good I
thought last week's game was important
for the legacy you can use that against
Montana he's not a thief he's our friend
yeah Peter Schrager from the NFL Network
good morning football co-host also Fox
sports.com senior national writer and
you can see the interview with Sean
McVeigh that will be on Sunday at 9:00
a.m. Eastern eight and a half hours
pregame show yeah yeah you know nine
hours would be too much eight and a half
is overkill yeah you don't want to do
that eight and a half hours do you have
a prediction I do
I think the Rams are winning really I do
high scoring well picked one of the
teams I think the Rams which I think
it's gonna be a bit of a shootout - I
feel like McVeigh and McDaniels is the
underrated superstar the survivor loves
belcheck McVeigh McDaniels is a dog and
that guy can draw up an offense and I
think they're gonna put up a ton of
yards - but I'm going with McVeigh and
Gulf young guard beats old guard and a
beauty yes we close that's where I
thought Peter would wait for you to make
your pick and then take it probably
could always change it if you sat down
with Belichick instead of McVeigh
I love that he's really sweet you're a
true journalist it Peter thank you for
coming back for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]